hello
i'm shekhar bhavar i'm the product
manager for data catalog
uh working for google cloud and i'm here
to talk about data catalog for
data discovery and metadata management
i'm going to be joined by shruti thalker
from blackrock towards the end of the
presentation and she's going to share
their experience using data catalog for
blackrock purposes
so what is data catalog data catalog
simply put
enables users to discover understand and
manage
all their data sets so data catalog when
we released it in beta we got a num
we got a lot of feedback from customers
where they said this is great this is
live
due to search for my enterprise data
assets but
they told us that their data assets are
not only in gcp
but they are spread across multiple
silos some on-brand some
in other clouds and they wanted us to
help them discover
data across all their data science they
wanted one
unified single pane of glass and that is
what we deliver here today
an enterprise data catalog but before i
go into the details
of the data catalog service i want to
talk a little bit about the genesis
google faced this problem of too many
data assets and how to discover the
right data assets way before other
companies did
and so google internally built a data
catalog
and that data catalog is a very scalable
system it
indexes more than 100 million entries
and it's being used actively
by tens of thousands of googlers google
also published a paper
on this it's called the goods paper you
can easily find it
the goods paper outlines a number of
techniques and technologies
so this is the background the data
catalog service i'm going to talk about
is our initiative to externalize the
system that we built for ourselves
if there is one slide that captures the
essence of what data catalog is today it
is this slide
so when we tried to build the data
catalog we wanted to do something
different from what the traditional
catalogs do
the traditional catalogs require users
to do a lot of heavy lifting
they require users to register their
data assets explicitly one by one
and the first thing we wanted to do is
to automate the process
the goal here is to create a smart
catalog so
data catalog automatically syncs the
technical metadata from data sources
like bigquery pub sub
and cloud storage so if you create a new
table in bigquery
you don't need to register anything
within three seconds
that table shows up in data so that's a
very
very useful feature for a lot of our
customers the second thing that i want
to highlight here is the auto tagging of
pii data
through our integration with dlp so our
customers tell us that they have
thousands of tables hundreds of columns
in each table and often the column names
don't let on as to
whether it has pi data or not so dlp as
some of you might know stand for
data loss prevention it's a service in
ga and we provide integration with dlp
that
enables you to use dlp to scan your data
you can do a full scan of the data or to
save money you can do sample scan
but dlp will identify the data it puts
semantics on data it says ah this is not
just any number
this could be a social security number
or a credit card number
and as a result it's able to auto detect
pir data
and dmp works in multiple modes in one
mode you can redact the data
in another mode you can also scale the
data but often customers do not want to
change the data they want to leave the
data as
is but they want to identify the data
and this integration with dlp
enables users to do exactly that dlp
identifies the data and creates tags to
specify that this particular column
is of the ipii and this is the type of
pi
now lastly we got a lot of feedback from
our customers that
you know they wanted to they wanted to
get metadata from all their disparate
data sources
so we modified our api to enable users
to write metadata from any source
but we didn't stop there we also created
open source connectors and we have put
them in github it's accessible to
everyone
using those open source connectors users
like yourself can
ingest metadata from hive oracle
sql server teradata redshift mysql
postgresql the list continues to grow we
have also added vertica green plum
and as you can see we can also ingest
with these connectors
you can also ingest technical metadata
from bi tools like looker and tableau
the end result is that data catalog
gives you a unified view
of all your data assets a single pane of
glass
to find them all right a little bit
about the data catalog architecture
because one of the question that often
comes up is that you know how robust is
this service how global is this service
how scalable is this service
so we have launched data catalog nga we
did that at the end of april
we have launched the service in 23
different regions
and multi regions so it's a global
service and it provides metadata
residency at rest
and the big there are many building
blocks and the three big building
blocks are the real-time and batch
sinkers
that bring metadata from various sources
and put it in the data catalog
then the metadata store itself which
stores all the metadata in the data
so metadata store is just a transaction
store we
use spanner to build the infrastructure
as you know spanner is a globally
distributed
strongly consistent database to a very
solid foundation
we also leverage the same google search
technology that powers gmail
and google drive and that gives us
search with access control built into it
gmail as you know has more than billion
users and so we know that this is a very
scalable technology
so data catalog is built on this very
strong foundation
in terms of innovation what we really
introduce that is new here is the
concept of structure tags
so the traditional catalogs usually
enable tags
usually enable users to put on tags but
those stacks are simple text strings and
as a result it is very hard
to capture complex metadata so we we
innovated and we said each tag
actually can be schematic stack but you
know since schema is taken for data we
call them not schematized but we call
them structure
so here is an example here is an
illustration of how the tags look like
in our catalog
each tag has multiple fields and each
field is of a different type
we support five different types we
support double
boolean string enumerated and data
and as a result you can create for
example the tags here in this diagram
on the left are applied at the table
level
the tags on the top are applied to the
column level so our structure
tags support is supported even at the
column level
and here is some illustration of how the
tax can be used because
the user journeys that need to be
supported for example
you know one of the common things that
happens when analysts come to work is
they say
okay did last night's get your job done
successfully do i have fresh
data and imagine if instead of you know
bringing data engineering and asking
them if
they could actually put these structure
tags in the data asset themselves
so in this illustration i show a data
injection tag and the analysts
are looking at it will know immediately
that the last night's etl job was
completed normally
100 000 records were processed hundred
thousand are added they're only
particular warnings and there are zero
errors
and they do not need to actually you
know ping data engineering and keep
asking them where it stands
data governance can be attached which
let users know what is the
classification of this data is it public
is it private is it confidential is it
regulatory
where in the life cycle is this data is
it in test in broad
in dev if there is a retention time that
is that is the constraint
on this who is the business owner what's
the corresponding on printing so there
is a whole
bunch of what we referred as business
metadata that users need
access to and there is no easy way of
providing this
you know people often ask me what's the
competition for the data catalog and
the answer is interestingly you know
google sheets excel spread
excel sheets wiki pages confluence pages
typically the metadata is spread all
over the place and there is no
easy way to make it available online
make it searchable
and our structure tags enable users to
exactly that
have another example here for data
quality now often one of the big
challenges analysts face
is that they discover a data asset but
they have no idea as to what's the
quality of this data is it actually
approved is it usable is it mostly
null how is what's the cardinality
what's the mean max medium
data catalog tags enable you to compute
all the data quality metrics and make it
available as business data
the pii tags are kind of self-evident
here right
so in this example i have two fields in
the pi tag one is
the has pii which is of type boolean and
it's set to true here
the second is type pii for the second
column it says hey
it's an ssn for the fourth column it
indicates that it's an email address
so the structure tags provide a very
powerful flexible and generic way to tap
all kinds of business metadata and make
it available to your users
so let's talk a little bit more about
the structure tanks
if there is a structure to the tag there
has to be a way to specify the structure
so we have the concept of templates we
didn't want to call it schema so it
could in terms
so on the left i show an example of a
template where you can say okay
and by the way all of this is completely
customizable so
if you as a user want to create a tag
template
and put five or six or twenty fields in
it you can do that
so in this example i have this field
called approved by data awareness
and it is of type boolean and then i
have data classification which is of
type enumerated and
in this enumerated type for my example i
choose to define public
sensitive confidential and regularity
regulatory as
possible choices now you as a user can
set your own choices you can set your
own enumerative types
right so there's a data lifecycle that's
also enumerated type
the delete by date uh you know i
mentioned a string here but actually it
can be date time now that we support
date time
there is has pi there is boolean those
are the templates now on the right side
i show the example of the tag
that they created using this template so
in this case approved by data governance
is set to true data classification is
set to sensitive etcetera
and as per the illustration once you
have a template you can create
tags using that template in the mold of
the template and then you attach it to
individual data assets
so you can think of this as some sort of
electronic sticky notes
those are now applied to every data
asset so whenever somebody looks at a
data asset
they get to see all the related metadata
right
now um how does how do people discover
these the metadata so the first thing is
you know we have google we like to think
we know how to do search
so we enable users to do simple keyword
search
so the business user can simply type a
keyword and find the data asset
but the power users among you who
actually want to do the drill down
queries or the needle in a haystack
query for them you also enable facet
search where you can
specifically say i want to limit my
search to this project id
or these project ids i want to look at
only bigquery or i want to look at only
views where the column matches a keyword
or it has certain tags where tag you
know has pis2
or a combination there of you can create
more complex query by combining it with
and and or
etc or and not so you have the full
power
of the search technology at your
disposal okay
one of the really important things that
i want to mention in our tagging
is that everything is integrated with
iam
security is built into data catalog from
the get go
so we have two personas here we have
data governor persona and let's say in
this case
data governor has full access to data
assets in project a b and c
and we have another persona data analyst
and data analyst
has full access to data assets in
project a but
metadata read only access to data sets
in project b
and no access at all the project c even
though
all the metadata resides in the search
index
when the data analyst looks for data
assets they see a different view
because in the 500 milliseconds that we
try to return results and we do like 98
percent of the time
we run probably hundred thousand apple
checks or access control checks
to figure out who can see what and this
is a really really important point for
many of our customers especially the
financial customers banks etc
because security is paramount and you
cannot compromise that and so
as i mentioned we have it built into it
now building
further on top of that security
framework
the tags themselves are also access
controlled
right so in this scenario we have data
governor persona
who has access to three different tags
and the data analyst persona has access
to only two of those stacks
because in many cases we have seen
customers especially the data governance
team
create tags where they put sensitive
information and they do not want others
to see this
and data catalog enables you to do that
so even the tags are
also under access control now the next
thing that i want to mention is that
ev you know we believe in a very open
system we believe that it's your
metadata you can do
whatever you want to do if you want to
bring in metadata from other systems
or you want to take metadata out we
enable you to do that
and in order for you to do this in bulk
as in bringing in large amounts of
metadata from outside
into our search index or take out the
metadata we enable
apis and we support seven language
libraries
so that you can create all the action
behind
every ui there is an api call so
everything is available through the api
and many of our customers actually have
their own front ends also and they use
the api to power the back end because
this is a much more scalable and
performing backup
and at this point i would like to
invite shruti from blackrock
to share her experience using data
catalog
the reasons why they chose to partner
with google and
how they achieve their objectives
you hi i'm shutti taka i work in active
equities at blackrock and i'm head of
vendor data and alphabet
i'm also the google administrator for
our google cloud instance in my team
so why data catalog well when we started
our journey
bringing alternative data into into
blackrock
and making it available for our
investors to use in their research and
analysis
we started to find that the data that
was coming in was very different to the
more
traditional financial data that already
existed within blackrock
within the data structures that were
made available to us
so what we were seeing were lots of very
dynamic
schemas lots of different formats and
vendors and working with vendors that
really didn't
connect with financial industry as a
rule
so the data was coming in lots of
different
file types as well on the other side
we had a spectrum of users we had people
both geographically diverse
from san francisco to hong kong from
sydney to london as well as people who
had different levels of comfortableness
with the with how to get to the data
we had people who are very very
comfortable just going into a server
going to a cli environment finding the
file that they need pulling it and
analyzing it
on the other side we had lots of users
who really needed that interface that
front end
which allowed them to go in and search
for
data using keywords or tags
and then be able to find that data and
then
work with it what we found was that we
really weren't seeing
something that could help us with both
of these
issues within blackrock and so we
decided to
go and talk to our colleagues at google
cloud to see if there was
um something that they could help us
with
so we started talking to google cloud in
2018
and we explained to them what we were
trying to do
and luckily for us at that time checker
was just putting
data catalog into alpha
so we were able to get in there and talk
to sheker and his team
and explain what we were trying to do
and he showed us
what that it was possible to find a
solution using
a google data catalog
because the catalog was in alpha when we
started working with
uh with google cloud it was it was
possible for us to both
help shape the product and find a
solution that would work for us
in tandem one of the great things about
the data catalog
is that it's really well integrated into
the google cloud ecosystem
so when you're looking at one
part of this puzzle which is the data
catalog you're not then having to build
uh apis or build connections in to
other parts of google it's already
connected to bigquery it's already
connected to storage
and compute so it's quite easy
for us to be able to come up with an
integrated
and complex front end which would really
provide our users a really powerful way
to find and analyze data
we were also able to very simply create
uh templates both on the front end to
start with and then as our templates
became more complicated
we worked with sheker and the team to um
put our templates into an excel file
which we could then upload directly via
python
this actually made our lives a lot
easier
and we were able to create tags as we
wanted them we were able to say okay
well
we would like asset management as a tag
we would also like uh different sectors
as tags and we were able to put them in
there wasn't anything that was pre
uh pre-created which really gave us the
freedom that
we needed to develop our own solution
as the catalog has moved to the
um to the general access phase
new functionality has been added
including
including automatic tagging and tagging
of sensitive information
we would like to start using that in the
next iteration of our products
following is a short demo of the product
that we built
using data catalog as our engine
hi and welcome to data predator data
data is an application that was created
on gcp
which relies on the gcp data catalog
for its core functionality data verdega
allows
users to use an intuitive and
user-friendly interface to try and find
all of the datasets available to them
and to do further simple analysis where
possible
when someone logs into data bodega
they'll be able to see
all of the cat space stats split out by
category
into different sections each one of the
files in each section
consists of a data set users can also
split
by sectors regions or style
the other way that people can search the
data is by looking at the intelligence
search on the left hand side here they
can enter a keyword
or if they know the table name or data
set the names of those
table names or data sets or they can do
a filter search
the filter search allows people to use
commonly
thought of tags and use those to do
searches
for this demo we're going to do a search
using intelligent search
i'm going to look for some of this data
this is data from the last publicly
available census
in the us as you can see we've got two
data sets the postal codes and the
we click on geospatial postal codes it
will open up the data set
and show me all of the tables available
there as you can see there's a near
single data table available
if i click on that on the right hand
side you will notice that we now see
a preview of the table as well as some
information that allows the user to
understand how fresh the data is and
also if they need permission to the data
in gcp and bigquery what project name to
ask for permission for
you can see that we can also show people
the top 50 rows of
each dataset that is available this is
refreshed
on a nightly basis and the only point of
this is to allow people to have an
idea of what the data set looks like
what kind of numbers are involved etc
you can also download this data as a csv
if needed
the other tab available here is the
analysis tab
if you click on here and the dataset has
time series data
there will be some simple graphing that
can be possible
you can also however open the data
directly in bigquery
if you have access already in tableau
or you can download the data dictionary
if
that's available the way we created this
application is we went into data um data
bodega
project in dcp we called it mosaic
and we went and created a bunch of data
tags
tag templates now the reason we created
so many
was that we needed to have multi-select
on some of our
tags such as region or country
and the only way to do that was to
create a region or country tag template
and have boolean yes or no on there
fortunately we were able to work with
google
to help us create the tag templates in
a format in excel which we were able to
then just upload into
gcp using python this made things a lot
easier and quicker than creating the tag
templates
on the front end we then went through
all of our data sets in bigquery
and tagged all of them using these tag
templates
the next step is to start auto tagging
datasets as they come in and are
onboarded using various data
data attributes that are made available
to us at the point of onboarding
this is a quick foray into what can be
built using
data catalog we've found it incredibly
useful to be able to go in
and connect and
allow users to go in and search for data
without knowing the name of the dataset
or knowing particular attributes of the
dataset and only knowing
roughly the topic that they're looking
for we hope to work further with google
to create more functionality and more
depth to
our product using data catalog thank you
shruti for that wonderful presentation
and and the demo so what are the next
things you can do as a user
the first thing i want to point out is
that you can launch data catalog
right away there is no setup required
data catalog indexes all the metadata in
the background continuously
so all you need to do is to go to this
particular link the
console.cloud.google.com go to data
catalog
you can select a project that you want
to start using just enable the api
and all the data assets are already
discovered into you
just with a simple keyword search or the
powerful search language
you can also use dlp to auto tag pii
data in data catalog
the dlp integration is available through
the dlpu-1
it is also available through the api and
this link gives you the details of how
to do this
to tag pii data at the table level
as well as polymer and lastly
if you are one of the users who has data
scattered in all these different silos
and you're finding it really really hard
to discover those data assets
you can use one of our connectors
and all the connectors are listed in the
google's github repo
you can download them their open source
connectors and you can start using them
right away happy data discovery journey